TILL THE ONE TIME YOU DON'T.
IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS PATH TO
FOLLOW.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
YOU WERE AMBASSADOR TO THE U.N.
DURING GEORGE W. BUSH'S TENURE
DURING THE WARS IN AFGHANISTAN
AND IRAQ.
HE, YOUR FIRST BIG BOSS, I GUESS
YOU COULD SAY, SAID THIS THIS
WEEK.
>> I THINK IT IS, YEAH.
I THINK BECAUSE I THINK THE
CONSEQUENCE ARE GOING TO BE
UNBELIEVABLY BAD.
AND I'M SAD.
I SPENT -- LAURA AND I SPENT A
LOT OF TIME WITH AFGHAN WOMEN,
AND THEY'RE SCARED.
AND I THINK ABOUT ALL THE
INTERPRETERS AND PEOPLE THAT
HELPED, NOT ONLY U.S. TROOPS,
BUT NATO TROOPS, AND THEY'RE
JUST -- IT SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE LEFT BEHIND TO BE
SLAUGHTERED BY THESE VERY BRUTAL
PEOPLE.
AND IT BREAKS MY HEART.
>> BUSH, TO BE CLEAR, WAS ASKED
IF IT WAS A MISTAKE, AND HE
SAID, I THINK IT IS.
I KNEW YOU AGREE WITH HIM ON
THAT, PERHAPS FOR I THINK
SINGULARLY YOUR GUIDING REASON
MIGHT BE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THAT
IN A MOMENT.
>>> BUT FIRST, WHY IS BUSH
BLASTING BIDEN NOW WHEN, YOU
KNOW, EVEN AS YOU HAVE SAID,
TRUMP WAS GOING TO DO THE SAME
THING?
WHY IS HE DOING THIS NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK PRESIDENT BUSH
HAS DONE SOMETHING REALLY
REMARKABLE.
IT'S HOW FORMER PRESIDENTS OUGHT
TO BEHAVE.
HE'S TRIED TO STAY OUT OF
POLITICS, AND IT'S BEEN VERY
RARE WHEN HE'S COME FORWARD AND
SAID ANYTHING LIKE THE PASSAGE
YOU JUST SHOWED.
BUT I THINK IT'S BECAUSE HE
REMEMBERS 9/11.
IT'S 20 YEARS AGO NOW AND SOME
PEOPLE WEREN'T BORN AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T REMEMBER VERY WELL.
GEORGE W. BUSH IS NEVER GOING TO
FORGET IT.
I THINK THOSE OF US WHO WERE IN
HIS ADMINISTRATION AT THE TIME
ARE NEVER GOING TO FORGET IT.
AND THE REASON WE WENT INTO
AFGHANISTAN WAS TO PUNISH THOSE
WHO DID IT AND MAKE SURE IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
AND THAT REALLY IS THE RISK THAT
WE FACE NOW.
THE CONCERN THAT BUSH HAS SHOWN
FOR THE PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN I
THINK IS VERY REAL, VERY DEEP,
AND WIDELY SHARED AMONG THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> IT IS WIDELY SHARED.
WHEN YOU'VE BEEN ASKED ABOUT THE
REASON TO STAY, YOU SAY IT'S IN
THE GUIDING INTERESTS OF
AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY.
YOU SAY THERE COULD BE ANOTHER
ATTACK ON THE HOMELAND, THAT IT
WOULD BE NATIONAL SECURITY
MALPRACTICE TO SORT OF OPEN UP
THE POSSIBILITY FOR THAT.
BUT I WANT YOU TO LISTEN, IF YOU
COULD, TO WHAT GENERAL DAVID
PETRAEUS WHO COMMANDED TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN SAID WHEN I ASKED
HIM ABOUT THERE BECOMING A
THREAT TO THE HOMELAND BECAUSE
OF THIS DRAW DOWN.
>> I'M NOT AS CONVINCED THAT
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO THREATEN
OUR HOMELAND THE WAY AL QAEDA
DID WHEN IT PLANNED THE 9/11
ATTACKS ON AFGHAN SOIL UNDER
TALIBAN CONTROL, AND ALSO
CONDUCTED THE INITIAL TRAINING
OF THE ATTACKSERS THERE.
THAT WOULD TAKE A GOOD BIT
LONGER, AND I DON'T THINK THEY
HAVE THAT CAPABILITY.
MOREOVER, I'M MUCH MORE
CONFIDENT IN THE CAPABILITY OF
U.S. INTELLIGENCE AND A VARIETY
OF OTHER PROCESSES,
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO FORTH THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
WE DETECT SOMETHING AKIN TO A
9/11 ATTACK.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THE RISK
OF A TERRORIST ATTACK FROM
AFGHANISTAN IS GOING TO COME THE
DAY AFTER TALIBAN TAKES BACK
OVER.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE MORE
TIME AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
RISK IS.
I WOULD RATHER DEFEND INNOCENT
AMERICAN CIVILIANS THERE THAN IN
THE STREETS AND THE SKIES OVER
AMERICA.
AND NUMBER TWO, THERE IS ANOTHER
ASPECT TO THIS.
IT'S NOT JUST TERRORISM IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IF TALIBAN TAKES BACK OVER, THE
HAND OF THE EXTREMIST IN
PAKISTAN WILL BE STRENGTHENED
AND THE RISK OF A PAKISTANI
TALIBAN TAKE OVER OF THAT
GOVERNMENT INCREASES
SUBSTANTIALLY UNFORTUNATELY.
AND SUCH A GOVERNMENT WOULD HAVE
CONTROLS OF DOZENS OR SCORES OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS WHICH EVERYBODY
OUGHT TO BE WORRIED ABOUT, AND
WE LOSE OUR ABILITY TO WATCH ON
THE WEST OF AFGHANISTAN WHAT
IRAN IS UP TO.
THIS WAS A CENTRAL STRATEGIC
POSITION FOR THE UNITED STATES.
WE'RE GIVING IT AWAY.
WE'RE GETTING NOTHING IN RETURN.
>> BUT HE STILL THINKS THAT
THERE ARE ORGANIZATIONS, THAT
THERE IS INTEL IN PLACE THAT IS
GOING TO PREVENT EVEN WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING.
>> WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, I DON'T
THINK IT'S ENOUGH.
THERE'S SIMPLY NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
BEING ON THE GROUND.
AND FOR NOT JUST THE MILITARY
FORCES THAT ARE THERE, BUT THE
OTHER CAPABILITIES THAT WE HAVE
THAT WE CAN'T SUSTAIN WITHOUT
THE MILITARY BEING THERE.
>> SO THAT IS A FOREVER WAR.
>> WELL, I THINK THE THREAT OF
TERRORISM IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
IT'S NOT LIKE AMERICAN TROOPS
HAVE BEEN CONDUCTING A D-DAY
EVERY DAY FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS.
WE HAVE HAD FOREIGN DEPLOYMENTS
SINCE WORLD WAR II FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME BECAUSE IT'S IN
OUR NATIONAL INTEREST.
THE QUESTION ISN'T DO YOU LIKE
THE LENGTH OF THE WAR OR NOT.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU DO
TO BEST PROTECT AMERICA.
>> AMERICANS DON'T WANT IT.
>> AMERICANS HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN
THE ARGUMENTS FOR THE LAST 15
YEARS.
>> YOU KNOW, SIR, THEY'VE BEEN
GIVEN ALL OF THE ARGUMENTS.
>> NO, THEY HAVEN'T, THEY HAVE
NOT.
ONE OF THE IRONIES IS THE
OPPONENTS OF OUR PRESENCE IN
AFGHANISTAN HAS CONVINCED PEOPLE
WE'RE THERE PURELY AS AN ACT OF
CHARITY FOR THE AFGHANS.
MANY AMERICANS WOULD SAY IT'S
TIME FOR THEM TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
THE POINT IS WE WERE THERE FOR
AMERICANS.
THE POINT WASN'T MADE BY TRUMP,
BIDEN DOESN'T AGREE WITH IT AND
IT WASN'T MADE BY OBAMA.
>> GENERAL DAVID PETRAEUS IS
RESPECTED ON THE GROUND AND HE
DOESN'T AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
I GUESS MY POINT IS THE
AMERICANS HAVE REASON IN AN
EDUCATED WAY TAKING IN THE
OPINIONS OF EXPERTS TO SAY, YES,
THAT CONFIRMS THAT THERE SHOULD
NOT BE U.S. TROOPS THERE.
>> THAT MAY BE THEIR OPINION.
I'M NOT DISPUTING THE SURVEY AS
CORRECT.
I THINK THE ARGUMENTS HAVE NOT
BEEN MADE BY THE TOP LEADERSHIP
OF AMERICA LONG ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO CONVINCE THEM.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN ABSENCE OF
DEBATE, IT'S VERY EASY FOR
PEOPLE TO GET A MISIMPRESSION.
THIS IS AN ACT OF NATIONAL
SECURITY MALPRACTICE, I THINK,
BOTH BY THE TRUMP AND BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATIONS.
AND I FEAR GREATLY, BUT IT'S
INNOCENT PEOPLE WHO WILL PAY THE
PRICE.
>> DO YOU LOOK BACK ON THE
MISTAKES MADE DURING THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION AND REALIZE THAT
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH WHY
AMERICANS THINK THAT THIS IS NOT
A GOOD IDEA?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
NECESSARILY THOUGHT THROUGH
WHAT'S RIGHT AND WHAT'S WRONG
ABOUT IT.
WHAT WAS RIGHT WAS TO STRIKE AL
QAEDA AND TO DO THE DAMAGE TO IT
THAT WE DID.
I THINK WHERE WE VEERED OFF IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION WAS NATION
BUILDING, WHETHER IT'S IN
AFGHANISTAN OR IRAQ.
AND I COME BACK TO MY BASIC
POINT, WE'RE NOT THERE FOR THEM.
WE'RE THERE FOR US.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BUILD THEIR
NATION FOR THEM.
THEY'RE GOING TO BUILD IT.
BUT WHETHER WE'RE DEPLOYED THERE
AS WHETHER WE'RE DEPLOYED IN
GERMANY, SOUTH KOREA OR JAPAN
DEPENDS ON A JUDGMENT WHAT'S IN
OUR INTEREST.
AND TO GIVE THOSE POSITIONS UP I
THINK IS A BIG MISTAKE.
>> MANY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
AFGHANISTAN AND GERMANY AND
AFGHANISTAN AND JAPAN.
>> GERMANY, THE DEPLOYMENTS IN
GERMANY AND JAPAN WERE PART OF A
VERY LONG WAR, VERY LONG -- A
45-YEAR-LONG WAR WITH COMMUNISM.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT AMERICAN LEADERS
EXPLAINED TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THEY WERE WILLING TO
SUSTAIN --
>> THERE WAS NO SOCIAL MEDIA,
RIGHT?
>> LOOK, LOOK, SOCIAL MEDIA
DON'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE.
IT'S A QUESTION OF LEADERSHIP.
YOU CAN CONVEY IT THROUGH A LOT
OF DIFFERENT MEASURES.
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT STARTED THE
FIRESIDE CHAT OVER RADIO.
LEADERS CAN USE THE MEDIA.
MEDIA SHOULDN'T USE THE LEADERS.
IF LEADERS ARE MAKING THE CASE
ABOUT WHAT AMERICA'S STRATEGIC
CASES INTERESTS ARE, AMERICANS
WILL SUPPORT IT AS THEY DID
DURING THE COLD WAR.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE PARALLELS
BETWEEN AFGHANISTAN AND VIETNAM?
>> WELL, I THINK, I THINK THE
PARALLELS THAT PEOPLE ARE
DRAWING ARE INCORRECT AT THIS
POINT.
THE ISSUE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
AFGHANISTAN IS NOT CONTINUED
COMBAT OPERATIONS.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE IT
WAS SERIOUSLY A WAR THAT
INVOLVED AMERICAN TROOPS.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
MAKING SURE THAT TERRORISTS
DON'T TAKE SUFFICIENT BASE IN
AFGHANISTAN OR -- TRYING TO
ATTACK THE UNITED STATES.
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY WE THE
U.S., THE U.S. HASN'T BEEN AT
WAR IN THE CONVENTIONAL SENSE
WITH THE INVOLVEMENT OF U.S.
TROOPS.
>> I'M SAYING THE TERRORIST
THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES IS
NOT A CONVENTIONAL MILITARY
THREAT.
AND IT TAKES A DIFFERENT KIND OF
RESPONSE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO IN AFGHANISTAN.
SAYING, WELL, THE AFGHANS HAVE
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES IS A LITTLE
BIT LIKE SAYING, YOU KNOW, THE
BELGIANS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES AGAINST THE
GERMANS, AND IF THEY CAN'T, IT'S
A EUROPEAN PROBLEM.
IT'S A LONG WAY AWAY.
THE ISSUE IS NOT THE BELGIANS OR
THE AFGHANS.
THE ISSUE IS WHAT KEEPS AMERICA
THE SAFEST.
I THINK HAVING DEPLOYMENTS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND IN IRAQ TO
PREVENT THE TERRORISTS FROM
GETTING SUFFICIENT SANCTUARY SO
THEY CAN PLAN AND IMPLEMENT
ATTACKS ON THE UNITED STATES OR
OUR FRIENDS AND ALLIES VERY MUCH
IN THE INTEREST OF INNOCENT
AMERICAN CIVILIANS.
>> DID THE U.S. LOSE THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> NO, I THINK WE'VE WALKED AWAY
FROM IT.
I THINK IT'S A HUGE MISTAKE.
>> HOW CAN WALKING AWAY -- I
MEAN, CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT YOU
MEAN BY THAT?
>> BECAUSE WE WEREN'T DEFEATED.
YOU HAVE TO BE DEFEATED TO LOSE
A WAR.
WE'VE GIVEN UP BECAUSE WE'VE
LOST PATIENCE.
THAT'S A SAD COMMENTARY ABOUT
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION, BUT
IT'S NOT A DEFEAT FOR THE UNITED
STATES.
>> SO IT'S JUST ATTRITION, THEN,
BASICALLY.
>> IT'S A MISTAKE.
>> IT'S A MISTAKE AS YOU SAY.
I'M CURIOUS WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WE'VE HEARD
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN WHERE HE
SAID THAT YOU HAVE TO GET OUT,
RIGHT?
>> THE QUESTION IS A RISK
ASSESSMENT.
AND MY JUDGMENT IS THAT --
>> CAN I ASK YOU --
>> THE RISK TO AMERICAN
CIVILIANS.
>> YES, AND THERE IS
DISAGREEMENT ON THAT.
HIS POINT WAS YOU HAVE AMERICAN
TROOPS THERE, THE TALIBAN WAS
SLOWING DOWN ITS ATTACKS BECAUSE
THERE WERE OBVIOUSLY ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS AND THEY WERE
AWAITING THE WITHDRAWAL OF U.S.
TROOPS.
AND SO THEY ACTUALLY PULLED
BACK.
HE SAID TO MAINTAIN A U.S.
PRESENCE WOULD HAVE PUT U.S.
TROOPS AT CONSIDERABLE HARM.
AS YOU'RE AWARE, YOU HAVE THE
SONS, CERTAINLY -- I DON'T KNOW,
MAYBE THE DAUGHTERS AS WELL --
OF AFGHAN VETERANS WHO HAVE
SERVED IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> AND NEVER FORGET WHAT THE
TALIBA